[Music]
everybody V : 360 live pre-show starts
now oh yeah what's going on man
welcome to Conan 360 presented by AT&T
and we are here with Conan himself live
at the roof of this breakfast theater oh
yeah and what a roof it is huh
incredibly it's probably the most well
lit haunted place I've ever seen it's
incredible yeah when you guys heard that
you got a gig you were probably happy
and then you heard it was Conan you were
like this is great and then when they
said it's on a roof in San Diego be
honest was there a drop in excitement
yeah a job you're like this is gonna be
indoors
yeah those jobs are mature man blacks
white Rex done very quickly and I did
not want to be outside and then I saw
all the Jamie Foxx posters and I was
like you know I'm comfortable well guess
what you guys did an amazing job
yesterday the reviews are in okay forget
Conan's comic-con show that says right
here the 360 pre-show is where it's at
that's variety of people row now no no
that's actually a variety okay the conan
360 show far superior to conan makes you
kind of hate conan that's Entertainment
Weekly wow the sound I feel like that's
less good on us and just more shows
people slate magazine every second of
the 360 show so far superior to anything
Cohen's done in his career that Conan
should be fired immediately the reviews
I just got to say you know for you guys
that arbitrarily moving are we gonna do
that again yeah yeah that was just
getting out of that bit immediately yeah
no you guys let me tell you something I
am I think you're doing a great job I
really like you guys we have good
chemistry and you're willing to work on
a roof I can't try you what that means
yeah my uncle worked on a roof once but
it was not as fun no cameras he's just
not building a roof really he's supposed
to be there yeah so that was very hot
when I was a kid that's a very real
thing I was banned from watching your
show was a true very religious Arab and
they saw masturbating bear my mom said
that is
fools entertainment and the fools point
you right to the devil oh wow yeah I'll
tell you a true story
about three months ago my son who's 11
came up to me and he said dad what's
pornography and I said well that's the
real conversation we should talk about
that with your mom I said I'm just
curious thinking he got this at school
where did you hear this and he said it
was on a Simpsons episode that you wrote
I know he has to no I did not I kept him
away from the Simpsons but he wanted to
watch The Simpsons and someone you know
now that you can binge watch all of them
he's only allowed like half an hour of
TV a day but he just uses every single
one of the Simpsons and he now knows
more about that show than I do which is
crazy
yeah I gotta tell you this is a true
story because our two stories were true
you look like someone who's gonna say
something like oh man that's just gonna
be a total lie yeah Burt restore my dad
set me down talked to me about the birds
and the bees mm-hmm and I was 18 years
old and had had sex plenty of times
right so he's just very late he said
when you were 18 yeah he's like hey you
know we need to talk about like dad this
is very late and you had like a woman on
each arm
it would have caught him on yeah with
Maggie loose come on we have something
going on right he was like listen I mean
the tuna sandwich before they're really
great we're in a great subtle way to say
you lost your virginity very early we're
all being vulnerable we're all live dog
anything happy yeah my father sat me
down to talk about the birds and the
bees and it actually was quite helpful
was it yeah you actually learned a lot I
was 44 the point is I learned a great
deal listen we're in 360 yeah and I
can't stress that enough no if you're
worrying is that they have to strap on a
device or something right yeah if
they're rich see everything going north
check out the shoes if you see a very
low quality video on the Conan YouTube
person and get the word out there yes I
think I'm very unimpressive on camera
but come on in person let's talk about
this and don't be afraid to be attracted
but I'm a guy that works out I'm tall
Yeah right
yeah Utah so I already hate it the hell
man don't hate that you could have a
fantastic career plenty of and also
there's a lot of performers a lot
shorter than you that are doing great
that's that is that right yeah yes I'm
looking forward to death yeah Kevin Hart
Kevin all right man go yes what they say
it says IMDB trivia Kevin Hart is as
tall as the stove
I saw the stove yeah that's what it says
oh yeah you know don't you wish you were
here with us right now you should be on
this roof experiencing what we're
experiencing experience you're not this
body let's go this way now everyone go
in the same direction you just work out
just right before your show what's that
Priya what did they even work out what's
that stuff Zeke yeah to get this
physique I use kettlebells okay I also I
pull trucks that have been put into
neutral I just pulled them with long
chains look I'm talking 18 wheelers okay
one of his pickup trucks but 18 wheelers
yeah I like the effect of you
interviewing me but walking away at the
same time that tells the viewer at home
that you're disinterested oh yeah you
don't care but tell me about like you
know your family life okay that sounds
really painful Conan tell me more you
know what I gotta do I gotta go prepare
our show this is fun actually you guys
have a good chemistry
I like this environment it makes me
think that I'm spending way too much
money making my ship this is just as fun
I don't you know we don't need why don't
you do that
it was crazy you have to be down there
because I saw you with Will Smith and
that was insane yeah Smith so what
you're saying is that you were finally
impressed when you saw not me but me
with Will Smith and then you were blown
away because he's doing all right now
you're doing better than I'm being
honest I started in an honest note and I
can't break that's a mistake yeah I like
my holding I like your take better that
scene the combination of Will Smith and
Conan was exciting yeah on the
commercial break Will Smith would go out
and he would take photos I told him you
should be our warm-up guy for the crowd
because
yeah he doesn't have to be that up and
he doesn't have to be that nice to the
crowd but he is so he comes out he does
a great segment but then he runs out
into the audience and I think took a
selfie with everyone during the
commercial crazy people were jumping
over already was amazing hissing no no I
wasn't hissing I was drinking heavily
yeah during the I am so you know
famously you know sort of creepy and can
I say the word Dickie yes during the
commercial breaks I am covered in a
blanket so that the audience can't enjoy
me during the commercials people come
out and they put a blanket over me and I
stand there bored yeah exactly I don't
even know what that means
meaning I heard I heard a guy say it
outside of like that sounds like a nerdy
thing saying guys are 1/8 as old as I am
and I admire that you have all this life
I'm very close to the end I'm gonna go
downstairs now and like I say again warm
waxes will be applied to me nice by a
bunch of young men and then I'll be
ready to do my show in wax coating you
guys on the flip-flop is that a thing
that people say you can say that hey you
can wear I know I just hate it I hate it
here all right you guys later bye
Conan yeah I'm just assuming y'all the
clapping man yeah that was awesome
so we're gonna have special guests like
that whole show long yes I know and
hopefully we'll be able to track down
some of the cast members look at this
you have your own show this is our time
he has no sweat stains and I'm so mad oh
okay the viewers just went down by 50%
he needs some sunscreen for sure because
that is a very pale man so later in the
show I'm gonna be down by the artist
entrance just to catch some of the cast
members from Kingsman the Golden Circle
exactly that's gonna be dope we should
we should actually look at some of those
cameras right now that is the artist
camp down there so Wow one sides very
lit up by the Sun can't wait to get in
there man you're gonna be ignore like so
many famous people it's gonna be great
because you were down there yesterday
right and it was so great to get patted
on the back
as a normal man is excited because like
people were like very excited because
your thanks to AT&T we're I'm like
surprise and delight people passing out
sometimes tickets to people who don't
have to get so excited really excited
really exciting and then Will Smith
shows you realize who doesn't love you
which is everyone there call now you are
no longer a gift giver you are a direct
obstacle exactly we also be playing
games so most will be down there at the
lobby while we're waiting for those
those members to arrive we have games we
have this is the lobby we have a whole
glass case there if you can look around
360 with pop figures on there I'll be in
there I'm just very psyched to be inside
yeah all that beautiful there's a stage
camp Pam that's where the Statehouse
audience is loaded in who's picking
their nose I want to see that I want to
slightly digging in there for Colbert
were you a this is Mike when we check in
with this camp because you can see like
producers rushing last minute there's
all these big set pieces every time they
do a Conan show it at comic-con is like
huge set pieces a lot of sketch actors
right so that's really cool to see that
you'll be seeing that live later on
today and now we're back here where you
see us in this young tiki hut young Tiki
Tiki it's it's a mixture of Hawaiian
dream in a microwave right I like it a
lot and does a great job of trapping the
heat in yes oh I love it
originally they were like do you want to
be inside I was like no no give me a
thin tarp let's do a show at high noon
yeah that's great
all right we'll be and we'll be back
with some more Moses will be playing
some games right now we are going to
this airplane video right now I think is
my video okay behind the scenes of the
cold open that's exactly what you saw
that Wonder Woman cold open it's
hilarious we're gonna see a behind the
scenes look at that right now
[Applause]
okay 365 here's the latest I am God
knows where I am
vamsee don't come in an air-filled hour
we are gonna shoot the portion of the
cold open where I'm stranded by Andy
Richter and I have no way to get to
comic-con so what I do is I find a world
war one plane and I fly it which will
then take us nicely into a segment of a
very popular movie that's all I gotta
say
maybe this airs after you've already
seen the cold opening so you know that
it's Wonder Woman so I should even boy
anyway here we are it was in 1929
Travel their sort of assessment of its
day that's a pretty straight engine
two-seater plane and I'll be pertaining
to fly it
I don't really fly a plane but I like to
know about that I think it's all I have
for now and watch this
yeah
[Applause]
but you're gonna see that here back here
maybe taking the same shot putting our
plane over there playing yes see well
gal gadot see me crash no
[Applause]
[Music]
garbage
[Applause]
[Music]
oh good you were just well oh hey oh no
yeah welcome back to the Conan Live 360
pre-show yes brought to you in 360
degrees that's what that means presented
by AT&T yep and these people right here
are writers writers fan Andre do Boucher
that's me yeah dan cronin man what's
going on guy are you guys good man you
know I just had to ask you before we
went back live so I wouldn't mess it up
you didn't have to tell him you didn't
have to tell him I'm real but off
perfectly oh I'm really so it's been
kind of a mad dash to put this show
together what's it what's it like
putting a traveling Conan show together
yes it's a big ordeal you know one thing
that I bet people don't know is that
everything takes twice as long we're in
a bigger house so just getting a
character and a unitard from one side of
the stage to the next
everything is longer it's a lot of
waiting around it's just a bigger
production it's it's like our show back
home but just once you get everything
are all more unwieldy Brooks you realize
how much stuff we have to work with when
we're back in Burbank and now it's like
a hoarders house we just get when you
could cram it in and we bring stuff that
we might not even need but who knows
let's yeah yeah yeah we'll bring the
ninja outfits just in case you know that
you really believed in but that's gotten
cut oh yeah sure most of the time most
of the time but you mean specifically or
I would guess at comic-con because it
feels like to me like a lot of us that
pieces are you know I did I had an idea
last year that just didn't come together
and it had a lot of costumes and we shot
it up in LA but it was it was obviously
directly it was a cosplay drycleaners
because I just pictured all these people
sweating out here in line so it was so
they were trying to get it back it was a
dry cleaner that did just did shields
and unitards capes capes and codpieces
and thread I felt bad they it didn't
work why did you get sorry Scott I'm
sorry
the whole thing made the whole thing but
it never aired in there most of the
stuff that they bring down here though
that involves a huge set or anything
like that usually has a pretty good
chance at making like a bit called
astronauts only comm which was yeah a
dating website but just for astronauts
okay that didn't make it the whole funny
thing is just saying that sentence and
then that's right this show is built on
a history of volume I guess you know
yeah there's people Conan Robert Smigel
they started at SNL so I think that's a
show that produces way more than it
needs and then stuff for me so I think
early on when you get something cut I
remember I had when I first sketch it
ever did involve North Korean soldiers
it was like it was a really weird idea
but it got cut and I felt terrible about
it and all the other writers were like
dude that happens literally every day
for three generations right my children
will also have to do that
giant whale if it was last year the year
before that was tons of yeah it was like
a whale that escaped from that was that
was enormous yeah that was of work yeah
it was funny you know mechanical stuff
going through it to shoot water out so
there's tons of people involved in that
lots of money but it was it was funny
and it worked
yeah when you guys are writing a kid
there like go to things like like
strange that you have like we write
something like yo this is gonna work
nobody better tell me this is not good I
you know I think I just I just figured
if I just say something as loud as
possible whispers a lot to under head a
sketch that I was lucky to be in
recently if you look it up on Team Coco
it's called nut spoon and it was yes
based on a real insight that in the
control room there was a spoon to serve
you know a small paper plane it was
unreal
so he wrote that into a sketch and we
knew reading it like this is either
gonna absolutely die or Conan is just
gonna be like turn himself over to the
idea like such a small idea where you're
just talking to people on stage off
camera and then nuts food goes to this
whole last retail it gets through Conan
it's on the show and we're like again
like the audience is either gonna bail
on this right away order on board and
being out there it was like the toilet
board they're like they like this and it
was I got the feeling lots of people
have experience trying to pick up nuts
with a spoon and surely you've cornered
the market I met spoon sketches the best
nut spoon sketch really there was a
comic on bit we did I can't remember if
it was two years ago or last year the
the george RR martin was that two years
me Chris crispy anyway we'll be out of
here we're going to leave you with this
other interviewer yeah and you know what
no one will ever hear that story again
dan I'm gonna leave you with Chris hey
bird on the other building I want to
tell you about this cool desk piece Oh
in that brightest way that's great we
walk half but we won't have the well
what's one thing working on the show
that that fans would love to learn that
they might not be able to find out if
they look look mess up like using the
green we're actually a restaurant or our
show it's a functioning Italian
restaurant you have to know what door to
knock on I think people might be
surprised to know that like how well
everybody gets along together and how
like yeah all the different departments
are kind of I don't know it's like a
family like a one big dysfunctional
family
yeah how hard everyone in I mean yeah he
he pops into the writers room and hangs
out with us you know not every day but
yeah I could tell by the way he hangs
out with us he's funny funny he's funny
he's a good boss to have so yeah well
you can see Dan in the mixtape comedy
show August 11th at the Virgil in Los
Angeles and I greatest comedy albums
naked trampoline Hamlet and 20-sided
guard now available on iTunes follow
both of these men's ostrich and Dan on
do Bechet Abdul Boucher and at Cronin
who cares thank you guys so much for you
know it's hard thanks bye and now we're
gonna cut to our video of associate
producer George slansky who's a mystery
to all of us but essential keys out the
room as we set aside his mind for the
part two of conversations with Jordan
take us through the rest of your desk
here you talked a little bit about the
bags in the back now we have what are
what are these VCRs what's happening
this is a sack of equipment which what I
consider standard almost not worth
mentioning or explaining there's some
archival formats here such as VHS the
video home system which as the older
people will know beat out Betamax as the
home video format of choice in the 1980s
by the way it's a Betamax a superior
format well you may be confusing first
of all some people did think Betamax was
superior for me you may be confusing
Betamax with betacam and betacam SP
which were professional formats betacam
was and Betamax before it was a Sony
offering whereas VHS was JVC the
Japanese victor company a lot of people
don't realize that it was a big step
when Sony released the first VHS VCRs
they were in essence saying we admit
defeat we are going to adopt JVC's
format up on the Betamax but otherwise
around the desk there are various
objects of which may or may not be of
interest I have here a package of
pumpkin seeds now pumpkin seeds are the
highest vegetarian source of zinc zinc
is a mineral that surprisingly even in
the 21st century
even in the Western world as well as the
eastern world many people are deficient
in because diets have changed over the
years and zinc is an incredibly
important mineral one that's hard to get
from supplements and oysters are the
richest source of zinc on earth but
again for the vegetarians pumpkin seeds
are great options so that's a snack that
I keep here at all times in case I ever
need some excess zinc okay
the pepper grinder there I'm noticing
yeah the pepper grinder is simply
because we are busy people here at the
show and we don't leave for lunch so
obviously we do the next best thing and
eat lunch at our desk so I have certain
condiments here that I call upon quite
frequently I have a pepper grinder and
then it's important to grind your pepper
fresh because a lot of the flavor and
aroma comes from the oils which are
released once the peppercorn is cracked
already pre cracked pepper has lost all
of those oils and then I have a sea salt
the companion these are counterparts not
the same not opposite but counterpart
would be the perfect word for the use -
and sea salt is worth noting because
being from the sea as the name might
suggest it has natural minerals which
were present in the sea such as zinc
again in magnesium especially so that's
something else that is a good source of
minerals talking about this this is a
Lavazza espresso cup in this particular
unit was made by a company called IPA in
Italy industry of Port Salani and in
fact the same design has been made by a
number of companies over the years all
across Europe the ones that I first fell
in love with and the ones I have at home
were made by another italian company
called danke
these are IPA and in fact now I believe
Lavazza uses a company based in Portugal
to manufacture its cups also worth
noting is you have put a device in front
of me this is a 360 degree camera or so
it's called I consider it a compound
camera it's a combination of more than
one camera not unlike the compounds I
found in insects and other arthropods of
course the compound I
is made up of thousands in some cases
cases whoo that is all I can take a joke
Lansky boy I was he lost me at the
beginning but now we're gonna go ahead
and cut down the moses storm as the
artists insurance or he's gonna surprise
and delight some guests while he waits
for the people of the cast members of
Kingsman the Golden Circle check it out
thanks Chris yeah I'm down here at the
artists entrance this is really excited
all the cast from the kingdoms are about
to roll up right here
Kingsman at the Golden Circle about to
arrive right here and we're gonna
hopefully catch them on the way in that
lately see them get into the show and in
the meantime we have a bunch of rowdy
fans you guys ready to see Kings Bay who
does everyone want to see odd one in
unison definitely got all that they just
want to see Conan it's pretty exciting
vibe down here you could like feel the
energy how are you guys over on that
side we will not be visiting that side
because this is the side with the energy
energy how are you very cool they ice
they are nice right now these people are
on ice that's almost sounds like a
threatening term you guys are on ice
very thin ice how much have they paid
you to get this close $14 he just said
he said $14 guys we have some games to
get you in the mood and then maybe give
you some special tickets to the Conan
show thanks to our friends at AT&T I'll
show you guys what you're playing for
right now and give me those handles we
got a tote bag this is just filled with
circus peanuts everyone's least favorite
candy this is presented by AT&T is a
conan swag bag in addition to tickets
that's how it works you could just say I
take it and we got some fun things in
here like a towel think that's a towel
see a lot of sweaty people who could
very much use this right now
I'm not gonna put this on the street can
toss that to you and Yuri put this bag
together we also got
at an all-white hat look at that hat
you'll never wear once it gets dirty
we got a t-shirt check that out
coated t-shirt sleeveless just like
Conan wears and all of his pre-show its
pre-show thing and of course a mug check
that out yeah people like this people
thank you very much that although five
dollars I gave you to cheer for a mug
really paid off and what do you see this
do we see this do we see this do we see
this a deity assemble that bag oh we see
you we see you over there okay
[Music]
so I need someone who's very excited
who's ready to play Oh what do we have
arriving who do we have so we just had a
black Escalade show up this is probably
the cast of the Kingsmen Golden Circle
or it's someone who's very confused at
their uber drop-off point they burned a
lot of gas
get in here oh wow shading Tatum we just
had shading tantum show up immediately
went to the fans he immediately started
signing things
there's people grabbing this very
handsome man I've completely right I
completely forgot everything I was
supposed to say this lady was free
tickets for sure and my more handsome
maintaining Channing Moses Moses Moses
Moses Moses he's so hot I look I looked
at him I got a glance it's there's no
contest do you guys if I try to grab an
interview with him you got to cheer and
say interview him interview him because
then he could decide who gets tickets
[Music]
go again on that this is a pure
pandemonium down here right brain
tanning over what's your favorite White
House down is your favorite everyone's
favorite is Magic Mike but they don't
want to say that they don't want to say
who said Magic Mike who's those honest
people you know some dance moves from
Magic Mike that was never in there where
he went like this that's definitely a
move I'm gonna try to slip in that area
guys be cool Channing Tatum guys let's
let him get through this is very
exciting people are passing just having
him sign their rent checks right now you
guys hoping to grab a photo or
autographed photo have you met him
before look at this the king of the cell
face he's incredible I'm gonna maybe try
to see if I could grab this guy and
hopefully he doesn't karate chop me in
the neck people are shouting get his
face
[Music]
people are asking what's his favorite
cheese right now
he said feta it's an inside scoop that
he would Conan would never ask cuz he's
a professional and he's signing
everything chanting I grab you a quick
Conan live free show how's the fan
reaction been to this to this movie oh
man it's such a good feeling coming in 1
we have an amazing movie to like it's
it's part of it already beloved you know
movie from before I was like a fan fan
of the first movie that's why I want to
be in the second one so I mean it's that
I'm just happy that let me be in it yeah
and you plan on doing some dance moves
on the show tonight is incredible dancer
whether that happens thank you very much
that was Tatum Channing and we have
another SUV who do you guys think this
is going to this UV Pedro Pascal just
showed up this is incredible
Pedro again going straight to the fans
this whole cast is so nice we were a
little rushed yesterday who's a friend
of narcos trick question I'm a cop Pena
is incredible right Pedro Pascal he's
walking down the line right now signing
for fans it's pure pandemonium but these
guys show up people just love Amit
they're so excited it's such a great
vibe this is incredible Darren
Aaron its Karen Taran's entering he's
really rushed in there Terri guys how
exciting was that teryn just rushed in
that's fast is he's known for that he's
very fast this is incredible martial
artists conan's your hero I was three
years old
and he's the reason I am Who I am
honestly he makes me sabi and meeting
him would it's gonna make me cheery I
just think about it he's he's the most
important human being to me in my life
and that's incredible what's your name
Josh Thomas I do a YouTube talk show
because of him and he just he means the
world to me and he's like because he's
like a parent that I need my best friend
that's so great to hear man you should
come up and we're gonna play a game with
you okay so I'll make sure you get
through here as soon as these people get
through and we'll play a quick game and
you can actually be on the Conan
pre-show let's have a great now how's
that sound right now Pedro is Sonny feds
Pedro has a very intimidating you got
cue cards okay colin firth showing up
right now Colin Firth's just stepped out
of the SUV people are very excited to
see him this is even crazy people are
jumping over the barricades you guys are
watching the conan 360 live pre-show I'm
your host Moses storm we got Chris read
up on the roof
and right now we're at the artists
entrance in 360s you guys can scroll
around and see as that is Colin Firth
right there credible actor right how do
we give it Scala to go over here
what's your favorite Colin Firth movie
come on oh yeah mama man speech the King
King speech right I love that nine-hour
training montage in The King's Speech I
opted that's how I warm-up for this show
someone stands on my chest and we give
him about ten dollars and some shrimp
Wow
inside a incredibly tall man people are
into this he's all of these have
incredible big security guards that have
would have no problem tasing me at any
point it gets higher security I think
we're behind in we have Jeff Bridges you
showing up in a me inspired shirt very
relaxed man :
hope everyone quick question for the
Conan pre-show yeah I'm gonna yell Jeff
in this year while heals Jeff in that
ear what's it been like to do the second
movie there's more fans involved in this
one because they've seen the first one
they know what you guys are doing with
the spy movie what's it been like to do
a circle it's beginning to feel like
just one big blended project in a way
you know the first time we were blazing
a trail in a way we didn't know what it
was gonna shape up to be you have a
sense of it second one the world's
established and so and also I think
Matthew Warren was so confident
you know he's not an easily optimistic
guy you know he's if there's a problem
he wants to fix it this time I think he
had a good feeling about things and that
was contagious so I think I I loved it I
mean I put you at ease as an actor when
someone is so confident in their vision
yeah and also I mean not if they're crap
at what they do but you see the results
with him and when when he has an idea
it's a relief to be able to just give in
and say I trust you go for it it's a
card well thank you so much for talking
to us Carly congratulations on the movie
have a great show appreciate it
she want me to try to grab this one guys
go ahead put that in the chat if you
want me to grab Jeff's got a rush in
because the Conan show is about to start
these people got a lot of prep high for
you it's still the energy is just
picking up constantly down here is
absolutely incredible for someone who
hasn't slept that all night Jeff you
excited you just joined the cast of
Kings Bend how is it to be on such a fan
of the first one and now we get to do
this one it's great that's incredible
alright we'll have a great show we can't
wait to see you on this again you're
watching the conan 360 live show i'm
here at the artists entrance for the
king's benders are entering right behind
me I have V Halle Berry who's signing
autographs to a great job I cannot hear
my voice I cannot hear anything else
going on but this is absolutely
incredible down here there's just a
swarm of people around here I don't
think I've said absolutely incredible
more than I've ever said that word Haley
we're just Kali we're Olly so
again you're watching the conan 360 live
show right now we're watching Halle
Berry show up she's cast member of
Kingsman and the Golden Circle and there
she goes they buy us she's go to the
other side now to science advanced which
what's everyone's favorite Halle Berry
movie do you have a favorite Halle Berry
movie next to nothing excitement over
dinner so who doesn't have tickets
almost everyone I just almost started a
riot I would love to talk to you we got
Conan's because we could we let him
through really quick just up here to the
front I've got some bags I'll give you
I'll make sure you guys go get this the
spot back but can you just like straddle
this backpack we got a number one conan
fan with legitimate tears in his eyes so
let's uh okay so uh tell everyone at
home your what live right now on conan
360 what your name is my name is Josh
Thomas Josh Thomas has a YouTube channel
with Conan is a huge inspiration to him
and have a lot of energy if he saw you
he would he would tase you much like
Halle Berry's people wanted to tase me
yeah okay it's just so I started my
YouTube talk show and I have a live
studio audience just like him and every
day before my show I just say think of
it like every day that is so cool that
is so cool to hear I'm gonna play a
quick game with you if you can get two
out of three of these log lines right
we're gonna guest log lines from a movie
I'm gonna say the log line if you
guessed the movie right I'm gonna give
you one of the AT&T bags with all that
swag and tickets to the Conan show all
right
okay so the first one it's time to focus
up there's two tickets to that means
someone else you go right so the first
here's the first question for Sammy a
family of undercover superheroes while
trying to live a quiet suburban life are
forced into action to save the world
that's one we got one on the board one
more you only need one more to win okay
this is our second one what a pilot
crashes and tell I think you could get
it from that if anyone solve a Conan
cold-open let's just say pilot crashes
on an island the Wonder Woman no that's
- Wonder Woman yeah you know more of the
title than me three times I love ok so
last one a fast-talking mercenary with a
morbid sense of humor is subjected to a
rogue experiment we got we got Deadpool
someone just wanted a TNT gift bag with
tickets leaves to get that bag right
over here that is a conan 360 egg let's
set up look at that you got two tickets
right there thanks to AT&T your friends
you are seeing the Conan show today this
is incredible look at this reaction who
else wants ticks oh my gosh I don't know
what to say without these I don't know
what to say okay this is a this is the
greeting part where you guys got the
celebrities first did you guys make this
little horseshoe it's like bending out
so you guys could get closer
very clever where are you from from
Zeisel in Switzerland are you out here
just for comic-con and you just were
walking by and was like I saw a line of
people
I'll join that no no we're here since
11:00 a.m. yeah great okay are you guys
ready to play again with us this is
guests that movie logline I'm gonna tell
you a logline of a movie if you can get
two out of three of them correct then
you are getting an AT&T gift bag with
all this wagon there's towels and cups
and other things you'll throw away
immediately and then also two tickets to
the Conan show tonight the cast of The
King's Men okay
pocus up again tell us your names okay
for BRT almost got the name question
wrong here we go so the first one while
we wait for another cast member to
arrive got another suburban showing up a
group of astronauts gain superpowers
after a cosmic radiation explosion and
must use them to oppose the plans of
their enemy what logline does that movie
belong to Fantastic Four that's correct
we got one one answer correct over here
everyone go wild
it's too much power that I have here
it's too much power okay you got one
right and all you need is one more to
win a powerful but arrogant God is cast
from his planet to live amongst humans
where he soon becomes one of their
finest defenders and know that God is
not Conan dark ah that's close we got an
assist from someone in the back I hope
you give them at least the mug but okay
well that's enough for an AT&T gift bag
over here this is our very reluctant PA
Brian to ever appear on camera and there
you guys go that is far Switzerland
friends enjoy we're doing great how are
you what do you guys think this is in
the in the suburban showing up who do
you think this is
[Music]
it's Andy he before the show he insists
on looping the block guys here again
watching the conan 360 live pre-show
presented by AT&T we're at the artists
entrance right now in 360 were givin
away tickets to very excited fans and
and we're having the cast of the
Kingsmen and the golden circle show up
as we speak we've already seen Halle
Berry Jeff Bridges and Colin Firth enter
they they have very little time because
the Conan show is starting in a matter
of minutes
so they're just getting rushed in so
we're just kind of just grabbing I've
been manhandling these adults that are
just following their dreams I have one
more AT&T gift bag to give away and I
want to visit this section over here
you've been very helpful
[Music]
we have a game called the movie log la
yeah you do have it that's that okay
well then you win it's as easy as that
okay so we have a movie log line game I
will give you the log line to a movie
it's brief description of the movie and
you have to guess the title of that
movie are we into it are we into it okay
it's a very bad system I just have a
sheet of paper that's blowing in the
wind and giving you all the answers in
the near future
a weary mutant cares for an ailing so
we're playing with her are you guys are
gonna split this back up okay Logan look
at that what a shocking all we saw just
a suburban leave did everyone just see
that leave it seems like they're making
a making a loop okay Days of Future past
a super I just set the title like a
monster okay but now can anyone guess
the logline
to x-men's in the futures pass word for
word you can have my shirt
you could guess the logline to that
movie as close as possible
you've been chiming in Ubud chime in and
whoever he gets close to possible at
this log line I'm gonna give you that
AT&T bag we have a lot of assists has to
go back in time to stop the catastrophic
apocalyptic future of this new world I
said the movie and not what just
happened to me this morning the movie
you need to say spoiler alert what's the
sign you got hi Dave and then in
scribbling like a psychopath
we have Alison Brie will be mine it's
also in parentheses cuz like it's an
aside thing okay okay well you will for
sure be frisked by security 11 times
there's no way that won't happen okay
let's finish this this game up good one
more ATT bag to give out let's do
something a little harder these let's do
some Moses storm trivia that's who I am
that's the first time they've heard this
name how did I how did I get stood up on
prom was it a because I got the wrong
address B they sent me to an abandoned
fish factory that was decoy prom or just
one of those close enough you win an 18
t gift bag I've get that out that's two
tickets to the Conan show and a whole
swag bag you guys are watching the Conan
360 live show and Chris we're gonna go
back up to you on that very hot roof
Chris I got ya what's going on y'all
this is me Chris read on the roof of the
Conan 360 live pre-show if you see my
face I'm very angry because my partner
in crime just met Halle Berry and I'm
pissed about it but if you miss calling
last night man we got your back we got
some amazing highlights brought to you
by AT&T let's check those out right
[Music]
[Applause]
lots of special events taking place in
honor of comic-con yesterday at the san
diego library there was a Quidditch
tournament yes yes and trust me when a
bunch of adults get together to play
Quidditch there are no winners there
were people I'm sorry there was a whole
section that was so happy Conan let's
quit right now right now they're hiding
their broom I know white Walker is
another name for a Trump cabinet member
what what superhero smells too strongly
of Cologne uberman Oberman
[Applause]
[Music]
we're touching FEMA playing brothers Sam
and Dean Winchester Jared Padalecki and
Jensen Apple
[Applause]
[Music]
Luke who came crawling back well settle
in it's only two hours to San Diego
what's going on yeah those are all the
great highlights from yesterday we got
Moses we just that was a great fantastic
job I am very angry with you sir he met
Halle Berry in no I did not I don't know
if you saw that but I looked in her eyes
mm-hmm
yeah she looked away yeah that's the
only moment I ever wanted in my life man
we're back here it's me and my friend of
Moses hosting the 360
Coenen life was ended by AT&T I'm Chris
red hisses Moses storm we got a chat
going this is live streaming and I'm
gonna check in with the chat man
Jeremiah on the chat will subject my he
says again counting two kids are being
neglected because of this and I can't
stop watching but yet I have no clue
what I'm watching
Jeremiah take care of your children if
they're your children you didn't specify
whose kids they were I thought he's
talking about Conan's kids yeah which is
like crazy because Conan I think he has
babysitter I'm pretty sure Conan has his
kids in a black SUV just circling the
block right what it would a couple so
they could feel his presence right
Jeremiah man thanks for watching I hope
you figured out what you're watching
we've said it enough so I was I was
crazy down there it's crazy right he's
pure pandemonium people are yelling and
the whole cast is so nice they have
immediate they were so many line
straight for the fans yeah I had no idea
who I was right and why is this still
talking away talking yeah I would tell
y'all what else was said in this chat
but it's a lot of Channing Tatum just
saying his name which I said I would
hope to have that effect one day I got a
I got a in a real you did you know what
he didn't it didn't sound like he was
going as long as you wanted it to be
nothing follows this and they only got
like two Moses's and then the rest of
them like who's Moses again and you're
like right and they still couldn't
figure it out but he's very good man you
had him you played him well it was great
it was it was so much down there right
hey well we'll get into all of Moses
experiences right after we cut to this
video of Conan giving you a tour of so
necessity to are his assistants ona
yeah and her desk say hey Conan here
you're watching the 360 live pre-show
and now we've moved out to another
exciting part of the office here at
Warner Brothers this is my assistant
Sonam obsessions area hi Sona
how are you you and I have been together
how many years like two years how long
has it been eight to eight close enough
probably moving on soon anyway
sona's great sone and I are like peanut
butter and what what do we like not like
jelly because those go well together no
peanut butter and like sauerkraut yeah
with asbestos in it but it's whatever
and this is we can see what sone is
working on right here which is she's got
the New York Times crossword puzzle that
she works on every day I usually say hey
Sona this is really important I need
this done really quickly it's about the
show and she says I've got to finish my
New York Times and then oh and then
sodoku you do Sudoku sodoku everyday and
how does sudo quit work I don't even
know well Sudoku you just have to have
you can't repeat the numbers in the same
row column or a box and I do the easy
eight easy level medium level and hard
level good for you
thank you very much does it ever get in
the way of work probably a lot quite a
bit okay and then this is your desk area
it's usually it's actually cleaner than
what I've seen usually you have a lot of
conan stuff here although i found out
that this was a joel mchale bobblehead
that some fan turned into a Conan
O'Brien bobblehead I've never made this
putt why that is so rude to take someone
else's bobblehead lots of Conan dolls I
don't know how to feel about this one
this is the one that reflects me
probably most accurately right yes very
pale okay take it easy that's good
lots of fun stuff this is a picture of
Sona and you were remember when you were
young and you were a ballerina yes you
look really nice and happy there what
happened I grew up
let's take a look at other things here
I'm just looking around your desk
you've got Dwight Schrute bobblehead
again that can easily be converted into
a Conan bobblehead if you just make some
simple cosmetic changes what are you
drinking today usually water but what
else do you have during the day have you
ever had alcohol during the show
days like when you're working I yes yes
what did you have uh well like a few
days ago we had some champagne with some
Saint Germain in it which was good
champagne during the dirt during the day
yeah I mean you know it was just kind of
chill day so we we call it juice juice
time juice juice time
that's terrific zona oh and look this is
great this is a great sign for someone
who drinks alcohol at work you have up
and oh look there's some pictures if
there's me choking you with my tie
uh-huh it's nice to have that framed
there's me remember when I introduced
you to President Jimmy Carter and
Rosalynn Carter the first lady yeah it
was a pretty big day for you right you
know what it was that was very nice that
was you to do yeah
I'm paying you a compliment that's a
genuine couple this mustache sometimes
can be used for me to do an impression
of your father
so uh so uh please why don't you marry
sauna sauna please is that kind of what
he's like and he is a cool guy he's the
coolest guy but you got to admit it
fight you just can't across me quickly
you might think this is your father so
on a sauna in Attica a man of God more
like human skin tone that's rude yeah we
have Murray Murray wave we're way back
there I don't know if you can see Murray
Murray is Jeff Ross's assistant so she
really has a job she just thinks she has
to do she's constantly working because
Jeff actually works on the show I'm a
jackass and a fool and you enable me
you're an enabler and probably an
alcoholic and so we have a good time and
here's your wall-e right here this is so
nice okay
probably only friend and you're you're
an adult you're an adult okay I don't
know I think that pretty much takes you
through some oh and this is Sona trying
way too hard to put her Armenian pass
behind her she does this whenever people
coming to ask for her green card she's
like America I was born here
really I was born in this country she
washed up on shore here and I found her
in a bush and gave daughter English by
having her watch various soap operas on
TV Falcons crest okay I'm gonna go so
know what you enjoy this Korean beer
that they've put my face on my face is
on everything here it really is your
license be a hell it is okay that's us
peace out
say Tupac what I don't know isn't that a
thing kid he's Tupac I'm trying to be
with the kids Tupac peace out yeah we're
deer yeah that was crazy man welcome
back Riza juice juice zone yeah we do
it's Conan 360 livestream thank you guys
for tuning in
I've been here or one of your host Chris
read you can find me at a Chris read is
on Instagram and read set it on Twitter
I'm Moses storm and don't look for me
online there's a whole pass I don't want
you to see thank you guys for joining us
for the pre-show we're gonna cut down to
the stage in just moments the show is
starting right now yes I want to thank
the whole cast of Kingsman for just
stopping for at least a second to talk
to you they're so nice to talk to every
single fan man and they were so cool
also the Conan writers you have to
interview them and have them up here and
we enjoy Jordan C Lansky and his crazy
rants
sinus desk was awesome please tune in
tomorrow at the same time the Kona 360
livestream presented by AT&T man and
enjoy the show
downstairs
- now how do we get down from here we
just jump Rafe we need down get out
you
[Music]